[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening everyone tokyo game show
2022.
you are now watching
tgs official broadcasting for captain i
am kosuke here are you rnc for this
program
yesterday we had lots of new information
about street fighter 6 and today we have
developers to ask more about this game
so first of all
shuhei matsumoto the producer of street
fighter 6 and we also have takayuki
nakayama the director
i am shahiman's motor producer of street
fighter 6
for street fighter 6
so
as
it
pass for
this broadcasting
here i was on i saw that you were
on the live streaming yesterday
i also participated in dubbing
as well but the
there are lots of top secrets which i
will have to keep a secret until
yesterday
and it was applied um a rare opportunity
for me to participate straight father in
that way
and he probably will be able to
watch that once again as well okay then
let's
talk about the first information for
today so first of all i'd like to
introduce a four characters of which
went public yesterday and they are all
legend characters from the franchise and
is there any new actions or moves they
learned for this
new title
so first of all former us national
fighting champ and xvp of the masters
foundation can and we also have a
kind-hearted defender of nature blanca
today we would like to introduce moves
of two characters and we also would like
to see
them fighting as well let's have the
game play on the screen
first of all let's look at ken first
there are
new
moves you can learn first the one is
kaku
from the low kick and upper kick
and also there's stronger kick which is
a turning one
and the
there's the overdrive and
we
also have another new move which is
ryubikaku jumping dragon lush kick
and the
actually you can change your position
when you're in the air
and depending on the situation in the
bottle you can utilize this move
and let's look at blanca
lanka also learned some new moves as
well and the first one is
aerial rolling attack
it's a special
move
and it's
blanca icon which you can find at the
top of the screen and the actuator you
can use blanca chandles
and it's a
electric attack
and depending on the attack you use
there are different movements
and the it updates also reputation on
the opponents maybe as well yes there
are various ways to use it and you can
use it as a sealed so that you can get
more closer to
your opponent as well so that was about
knee
move and now we have a matsumoto-san and
myself here so we do
like try the fight
this is street fighter sick and we have
plastic type and modern type
the modern type is the one
with a simplified
manipulation and it has assist button so
that you can use assist comb in
easier way
and i would like to try that out
even though you are not familiar with
the street fighter you can still enjoy
it and for those who are familiar with
street fighter you can also enjoy it yes
okay let's
try it okay i'll play with blanca
modern type and i will
try
ken i was um
classic manipulation
that's very interesting
so now
player two
that they are taking the distance and
as you can see there are different
motions of characters
[Music]
they
are both doing well
big damage
there were some
combo attacks as well
you are playing with a classic
type
how are you gonna use blankachan those
so there's a commentary on commentary
wonderful
so you're in a difficult
situation producer
okay now the attack is
working
you won't
there was nothing i should um do
actually it was the first time for me to
listen to that as well
so probably after you go back you can
enjoy listening that as well
and the timing of the commentary was a
wonderful as well and
it makes the fighting more exciting
even though you're playing this alone
you can still enjoy this game and it was
a very heated fight and the actually i
wanted to
introduce another game so there's more
characters yes let's take out these
characters
from india
and a small wrestler looking to bring
the spot word while we have edmond honda
so he is
walking in such a mysterious way and now
he is
flying up in the air
and he has a lot of a special move he
has yoga fire and i holding button you
can change timing
than such a special move
and there's also yoga arch
which uh you must be familiar from
street fighter
5 and there's new attack
now he can
use yoga fire in the yoga comment
when he is flying up in the air
so he can exchange his opposition so
that he can take advantage in the game
and
also there's
yoga inferno
so actually it is a attack uh which you
can use on the ground as well
and also there's the weight like attack
like this
so there are
various
yoga fires and yoga inferno
and now let's look at edmond honda
from street fighter 5 there was attack
called katayari
and with 6 we also have that
[Music]
and this is
at that
the punch at the opponent
let's try the fight with
the two characters
okay i'll play honda with modern type
the first bomb
so let's look at the situation with
projectile
and now he is throwing the opponent
and by using a good distance
try
to attack from the air
hurricane
sorry actually it was a woman by
matsumoto-san
honda
so these are familiar characters for you
and as they learned
and the you can
enjoy the changing fighting style as
well so what's next
so when we are explaining
characters we also talked about training
mode
with straight fighter 6 we have some new
addition to the training mode so it's
easier to use everyone so this is what i
will need to
look at as well so we have
easy
setting or simple setting so let's up
the game
screen
when you open the main menu this is the
option you get
first of all we have empire practice
when you select this
you can
[Music]
update
your setting so that um you can practice
the move which is appropriate for that
particular setting
and the timing of attack is a quite
london yes it's all set like this the
next step let's look at
a practice to respond drive impact
when you select this
there's a random movement or driving
bugs
and you have to respond to that um
that is how this practice works
sorry the screen is quite unfair from
myself so
i had to actually respawn this but i
cannot
and we also have a flame meter
this is actually a wonderful one
so when you
have a move so that this is a flame we
have here yes
and there are the various um
attacks of which you can check
and actually this feature is here very
helpful for the development achievement
as well and this is what you can use for
your training
and this is such a good visualization
yes
so these are training modes that we have
which is um
easy to use from beginner to experienced
players that was
very good
mental it's a very interesting fighting
by combining gimmicks and rules
we can have a different feel to the
battle
and by far is different from usual as
well please take a look at that as well
so let's show the battle to you
got me
we wanted to
provide the opportunity to have fun
this is flip mastery
and you can see that where they're
coming from
well you don't have time to really look
at the people around you
to see where the opponents are coming
from
so if you
punch
at the right timing you can also return
it
the timing you miss the timing
both of them
really fun
we hear the cows too
but you can also have to watch
what the opponent is doing
looks like it's very spacious
so it's easier for you to look at the
gimmick
so you can have fun with your friends
and we have other gimmicks as well
you can have different ways of enjoying
the title except for regular fighting
next
i'm sure you
looking forward to finding more about it
yesterday
we showed some movies yesterday so i
know that you're exposed to it
but we want to show you the
beginning of the play of the world
tour this is in english
this there are three menus that we are
showing them to you for the first
i've been thinking about time man
strength
money
to power to fight
is it money authority a cool job a ton
of likes
okay okay
let's keep it simple
i want to be strong
can you believe it we got self-driving
cars the time's coming we'll be taking
rockets to mars and yet you still got
folks out there using their fists and
bodies to seek strength
yeah i hear you man
we're all about your fools
but
you know
if you want to know about strength you
just got to get to it
we fighting fools are all getting to it
on the streets
you my new recruit
kids take a breather
welcome
this is buckler security services i'm
luke the coach around here
you're here for basic training right
okay
let's get you measured up
[Music]
belongs to and we start with time motion
and you can create your own avatar
let's look at the function
body type
engender
preset
is also available
users
can make their own avatar as they like
and it's like a slider
wow
we can adjust it like this
you can also select the amount of
muscles
and skin color
and the body hair
you can create a character that you like
wrinkles you can choose wrinkles
wow
beard
you cannot finish it you will do this
forever
you can change the
straight fighters
you can choose
fire things maybe i'll
fast forward it
you can choose lots of characters
yeah
gotta say you're photogenic
oh alrighty well that should about wrap
up your enrollment
again
you can call me luke or just coach
okay then hope you're ready to begin
first let's go over the basics
there are many ways to enjoy world tour
sorry about that
tutorial for walking
first step anyway moving right along
i placed some panels on the floor you
see them
i want you to pass through every last
one and then make your way back to me
sound good
you can also change the camera angle
i didn't do we didn't do this
let's get right before it then
show me how you are with your fists
street fighters battle
tutorial for that as well
first we start with a modern
mode
and you can also select the crash mode
later
so you get used to it
it's fun if you can use your own
character
for tutorials
and for
attacking you can learn a lot in detail
okay
please look forward to it
i shouldn't have asked oh that's
okay right that about covers the basics
kind of boring right
i knew it
that's how the basics are
simple and boring
but remember even the biggest rockets
need a stable launching pad for takeoff
or else they're just gonna crash and
burn
you get me
coach how is any of that
gonna help him handle this
you might wondered food he was
let's use basic moves
and
beat up the other
[Music]
throw the other way oh and the one away
i got defeated
come on man
are you really gonna be the type to jump
before you think
but coach
that was the kind of situation i want to
learn to deal with
you're not here to punch bags either
right
ah right this is bosh he's signed up
with the same regimen you are
[Music]
but both of you are my trainees and you
joined at the same time
so play nice okay
coach
we both came here looking for strength
if both of us are trying to find that
strength sooner or later one of us is
going to get there first what happens to
the other person then
we all know that nobody's going to be
friends after that so why bother
pretending now
oh gosh my man that's a really tough
question you got to know what strength
means to you before you go looking for
it
you go looking for the wrong things and
you really might end up in that
situation someday but you know what you
can cross that bridge when you get to it
you two are still my plucky little
trainees
listen to what your coach says and put
your hearts into your training
focus on that
all right
okay
let's get back to business
you wanted something more practical
right
[Music]
well practicality comes in many forms
but if you want to start off on the
right foot in this city
hit the streets
we saw this much and we
feels like we can play it right away
i'm sure you want to see the rest of the
story
but please look forward to it
i'm very much excited
yes we are waiting for
more information
straight fighter 6
was announced in
june
and we received
lots of response and a lot of attention
thank you very much
so far
we have fighting street
street fighter 6
development team
challenging
incorporate the challenging battle
scenes
and we want to make them all available
at that
time of launch in 2023
we
and we want you to experience the battle
style
and we are making 18 characters to
make that available
we will keep adding contents
and characters
to the launch we have some time
but we will
keep you posted so
please stay tuned
thank you
now let's look at the world view and
character setting of street fighter 6
now
i'd like to invite one more guest
kaname fujioka they are director of
street fighter 6
i am our electoral street fighter 6
kaname fujioka thanks for having me
today
[Applause]
so we would like to
i hear about the character design so how
long have you been
involved alistair's a character design i
don't remember but actually it's a long
time i think it's been about three years
and how long have
you been with us yes um as you can guess
i am actually a little bit old and neat
i
was um attracted by the world view of
street fighter 2
and i joined captain as a designer
another time actually we had the
the people of whom
designed the 12 characters of form
street fighter 2 and zay told me a lot a
lot about how to design characters and i
was a
designer about for 10 years
and there was some structure change and
i
became a
designer and the i was the designer for
monster hunters and um actually i always
wanted to
be involved with street fighter buddy
i didn't have the opportunity in the
past and even so i was
designing the fighting game i didn't
have an opportunity and actually
nakayama-san is a good friend of mine
and i always
said to him that i want to do this i
want to do this and finally this time i
was able to
be
the art director of this game and
there's there's a new calendar luke and
kimberly so what was your motivation to
design these characters
so if you look at the
characters from street fighters they are
from various backgrounds and the various
fighting styles so
as you can see
they have various kinds of um
bodies as well and it's because of their
backgrounds and also their
fighting side as well so we are looked
at
from skeleton types for instance luke
who is a main character
and nakayama-san said that
luke is a
caucasian-american and the
that is why we
studied
the muscles of
caucasians then
luke has less fat but he has huge muscle
and the
he has and then background body we
wanted to
have a huge muscle on his back and also
he is very good at punching so that is
why we wanted to have good muscle on his
arms as well
so that he can have a
stronger punch and
next kimberly
muscles at the body center tends to be
bigger
and also
there's a huge muscle around the hip as
well but the
there's um
less muscle
and the because we wanted to have a
sharp movement so that is why we
designed kimberly this way and another
character jamie
jamie is a library character of
luke so that is why
we made him as an asian character
and as you can see he has a relatively
sharp muscle out to say but he has a
really
also
he
had some flexibility with his body as
well and that is reflected to the
character design
[Music]
dance dancer as well
and he can
do a very tricky
moves as well when the breakdowns did
such a
unique dance and it was a little bit
difficult for us to design so that is
why we use the motion capture
technology and we ask the helpful
of lake dance professional dancers so
let's look at how we
did with motion capture technology
so this is the basic um the style the
marshall
style however for his leg and moves it's
a little bit tricky and he is
yo he is um
professional dancers and there
are some tricks only he can do
so that is reflected to our game design
so
we
added a lot of movements to this
character
and we had a lot of discussion
on that as well
so that is why we had
many moves and it's very cool and it's
um very
good in a visual or graphic as well
and we wanted to connect the movement of
martial arts with the movement of dance
and we had so much fun
in designing this
so there are three new characters
and we also have some legend characters
as well so
did you have any difficulties in
designing
their movements
they have such a unique characteristics
honda dalshin
they have such strong characters
and we
spend a lot of time to think about what
we should do with them because we did
not want to kill their
uniqueness so he has such a huge
body because he has a small restaurant
and the the characteristic of his body
is a good balance between muscle and fat
and even
we designed his a movement we also used
a motion capture we invited the former
wrestler
so that we can
reflect
posture and movements of real small
wrestler
[Music]
so as you can see he has
long reach with his
arms and legs so it was a difficult bird
and also when you look at his face it
looks very serious and also
when he
um fire attack he also used um his upper
body very well as well so that is why we
did a lot of work with his facial
expression as well next
really like a body
he is not like a human so
again he has this massive massive body
but he also has flexibility so he can be
small he can be big so that is
not the characteristic of lanka so we
wanted to utilize that so how to
change his body and also we look at his
facial expression as well which is quite
different from normal human being
and
this was another very special technique
that he had this special facial
expression on blanca
and after the announcement of ken now
we have more main characters
so i want to introduce ken a little bit
as well
so i had lots of good memories with
street fighter 2 and compared to you
han is such a passionate character
he is a man of passion
and i wanted to
have a can in that way so that is what i
discussed with nakayama
and i saw the the world view of street
fighter 6 that goes well with that
series
and the passionate character of ken
and
this is
from street fighter 3 this is such a
cool
visual when this is such
impressive um scene for me so there's
some
design from the past so probably some of
you might notice um some of the
expressions from the past titles and i
want you to enjoy that as well
thank you very much that was about
character creation or character design
thank you very much for
letting us know about the background of
the development
so we talked about the characters of
street fighters
fix we are going to hear more
information
i'm going to repeat myself caused beta
test from
october 7th to 10th
we are going to stream it
at
playstation 5 xbox series x series s
and steam
[Music]
this is a good opportunity to experience
street fighter 6.
and
this is going to be a ruffle
that first comes first served
please apply for this beta test
this is to
decide the world's strongest champion of
the year
and all the players are having a fierce
battle
to be qualified
to a capcom 9
and they're fighting at capcom pro tour
2022 there's still opportunity for you
to
go there
we are having capcom pro tour world
warrior in 26 regions on the globe
we have a regular
games to gain points and we also have
regional final
tournaments if you win
in those tournaments you are qualified
to play in capcom cup nine
also
you will be nominated
to get japan esports union professional
license
at the national championship
i'm this also telling you about this for
the first time this is the
event for 35th anniversary we are going
to have a concert in shibuya
on january 29th
close on ticket
again this is going to be a ruffle style
this is going to be a live
performance
but this is going to be streamed live
you will hear all the songs
of historical street fighter
with street fighter 5 but we are going
to cover it with onitsuka tiger
apparently these dishes is
being produced and we hope to deliver
this to you
we
would like to make shoes as well
lastly
we have an exhibition
of street fighters
in osaka
starting on november 18 2022
at shinsaibashi pako in osaka
in the past we had this event in fukuoka
tokyo and kitakyushu
but this is an exhibition
for the 35th anniversary so we want to
hold this event in osaka next one
this is also exciting
street fighter 6
japanese image song
is
sing this again
and it's a version of 2023 it was
revived
have a movie to play for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa this is great
our staffs are also very excited about
it
not just this
but we have a special message from both
of them
from yokosinohara and titia
this is the japanese image song for
street fighter 6
we are singing this for the first time
in 28 years
20 years
it's been a long time
and i sang this very seriously for
recording
i wasn't sure if i could sing it
try to remember how it was 28 years ago
i think
this
song sounds more mature
if you're listening to it for the first
time
and also those who already know this
song i think it's still refreshing
to you
right this is
[Music]
is a
woman and
[Music]
yoga kind of overlap
i want to cheer all the fighters
that's
the message i wanted to send
relics
looks very built
in
so please listen to the relics very
carefully
please listen to
the song thank you
it's been streamed
at apple music and spotify and other
music sites
so you can go visit those sites to
listen to the music
we are running out of the time last
moment
in 2023
towards the release we are working very
hard
to develop
the end of street fighter 6 special
program thank you
you